-The password is..."peacock".
-Oh, slide. Sorry.
-Shh. Don't show her.
-Oh, my God. Okay.
-That's filthy.
-[ Sighs ]
-Are you ready?
-Wait, we have to do it tonight.
You can't take this much time.
That is ridiculous.
-Amy, are you ready?
-Thinking for 20 minutes.
-Yes, yes, yes, ready.
-One word.
-Plumage.
-Down?
-Ooh.
-Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Bird.
-Swan.
-Ooh. No.
-NBC.
-Peacock?
[ Bell dinging ]
-[ Laughs ]
-NBC.
-That works.
-Is "NBC" not a word?
-I guess that's one word.
I didn't hear a buzz
from the judges.
-'Cause NBC is not a word.
It's a lifestyle.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's your card.
-The password is..."jockey".
-We're gonna start with you,
Allison. Alright.
Remember, one word.
No acronyms.
Or initials.
-Oh, shoot.
-[ Humming ]
-Mm.
-Whenever you're ready, Allison.
-Take your time, Allison.
-Welcome back to "Last Call with
Carson Daly", everybody.
-Wait, that's implying that
she's taking a long time.
-Okay.
-Derby.
-Kentucky.
-Ooh. No.
-Rider.
-Jockey.
-Boom!
Oh, my.
-Yeah!
-4 to 5.
This is a barn burner.
James, we will start with you.
-The password is..."giggle".
-Just don't cheat. Please.
-Titter.
-Cow?
-Mm.
-Cow.
-What'd you say?
What did you say?
-I said "titter".
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
Raquel Welch.
Anyway.
Mmmm.
-Dolly Parton.
-Oh. I got my Slauson Cutoff.
-[ Laughs ]
-Not "teeter".
-Mm.
-Laugh,
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
-Cow? Titter?
-Did you just say "cow"?
Don't worry about the cow!
The cow is the wrong answer!
-Everyone keeps guessing "cow".
-Dan guessed something
that's totally wrong.
So, just remember "titter"
and "laugh".
-Not laughter?
-Alright, we're moving on.
-Dan, listen up.
[ Buzzer ]
-Thank you.
We've had laughter,
and what was yours? Titter.
-Titter.
-Laugh.
-Right, right.
-Alright.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Baby.
-Mm.
-[ Sighs ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Alright.
Alright, Amy.
-Mm, shy.
[ Laughter ]
-Shy?
-Shy.
[ Laughter ]
-Not chai. Not like the Chinese
word for tea.
-Shy. Shy.
Shy. "Baby", "laugh", "titter"
are [bleep], [bleep].
"Shy", "baby", "laugh",
"titter".
-Yeah, we have Red Hot Chili
Peppers right here.
-Are you going to guess?
-"Shy", "baby", "laugh",
"titter".
Alright. Thank you.
Judges, please.
[ Buzzer ]
Thank you. Alright.
-Dan, Jim.
-Down to two points.
-Gurgle.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Carrot.
-Oh.
-Very close.
-Carrot. Cow. Chai.
-Happy 4/20, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
-Funyun!
-Pillsbury.
Doughboy.
-Ah.
-Very good.
-What if I were to say...
Jiggle.
-Well, that's not fair.
-Well, you can rhyme it.
-You can?
-Yeah.
-It doesn't matter.
The word was "giggle"
-Alright.
-Oh.
-Alright. Now I'll give it to
you guys. Yeah.
-I'm so sorry. Giggle.
Don't listen to what
Dan says.
-Oh, really?
Carrot and cow?
Don't listen to what Dan --
of course.
-The password is..."toupee".
-Dan, you're going to start.
-Am I first?
-Alright. Come on.
-You read the word.
-Hairless.
-Hairless?
-Bald?
-Ooh. No
-Hairless.
I'm going to ignore that
and listen to what you say.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, Allison.
Oh, oh, watch it with your hand
there, Allison.
It's not charades.
-Wig?
Hairless. Wig.
Toupee?
-Yes!
-Oh!
-That's a win.
-That's it.
-That's a win right there.
You guys got it right there.
-Oh, nelly!
-Oh, my God.
-The password is...yuck.
-Lily, you're up first.
-Don't pay any attention
to my bandages.
Just focus on, you know,
what you're trying to do.
-Well, I don't know
if I can do that.
-It's hard for you to focus.
-I'm kind of I'm kind of
obsessed
with looking at that bandage.
[ Laughter ]
-You've got to move past it,
Lily. Get to the game.
-Okay.
We can do this.
-Team?
-No.
-No, that wasn't the guess.
It's a one word --
-She'll give you
one-word clue.
-But that would have been
the right answer.
Yeah.
It's one word to one word.
-You said, "We could do this,"
so I thought,
you know, "team".
-Okay, wait.
Okay, here's the thing.
Can I say it sounds like...
-No.
-No. No.
Don't say anything that rhymes
with this word. No.
Please don't -- in fact,
on television, you can't say --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I gotcha.
-Ick.
[ Laughter ]
-That was a full body
experience.
-I know. That was amazing.
-I thought you said
I can't do that.
-I know. Well, she just did it.
I don't know.
-I should have done that
to camera.
-[ Bleep ]
[ Laughter, applause ]
♪♪
-A quarter in the jar.
A quarter in the jar.
-All right.
That was incorrect.
-Am I shocked.
-Ick.
-You said same word.
-Same clue.
-I said what you said, kind of.
You said, "Eeeuch,"
and I said, "Ick".
-Oh.
-You're saying the word!
I'm not saying
the word. I'm saying...
[ Laughter ]
-You lose a point.
-Yeah, I lost a point.
-You lost a point.
-I'm carrying this team
right now.
-Yeah. It was "yuck".
-You don't say.
-[ Laughs ]
-I think Cole knew it.
-Cole knew it,
and he's being sarcastic.
Cole.
-Okay.
-Jane, next clue's for you.
-The password is...lollipop.
-Okay.
Jane, why don't you start off?
-Ooh. Ooh, this is good.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
This is a family show!
[ Funk music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you've given me --
-Candy on a stick.
-You've given me so many
choices.
-Did you hear what I said?
She has a hard of hearing.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't.
-Candy.
-Candy. Candy.
The clue is "candy".
-The clue is "candy".
-Candy.
[ Laughter ]
-Jane.
-Push-up?
-Oh. No.
-No, I couldn't
guess anything.
-Do I need to say anything here?
-Yes, you do.
-I think we got this, right?
-Oh, no.
-She said "candy".
Alright.
And now, what do you say?
-"Cane".
-It's my turn now.
We've already had this
erotic experience. It's my turn.
-Alright.
Are you going to say "cane"?
No.
-Unh-uh.
-Okay. Alright. Here you go.
Your one word clue is...
-Sucker.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Lollipop.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Wow.
That's an all-day one.
-I thought that he was
guessing it and said it wrong.
-How does "lollipop" go
with sticking your finger...
-Depends on what neighborhood
you're in.
-Lily.
-Hey, hey, hey.
-What? Jimmy.
-The password is...sting.
-Jimmy, why don't you
start us off? Clean.
-Bzz.
-[ Laughs ]
-You're looking
rather bee-wildered.
Bee?
-No.
No.
-Alright.
-Lily, you give now your clue.
Same word.
-Look at me.
[ Laughter ]
-No, look at me!
The game's much harder
when you look at me.
I like it that way.
I like you looking over.
-Ouch!
-Mosquito?
-No!
-This is fantastic.
Alright.
I feel like we got this.
-Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-You have "Bzz",
you have "Ouch".
-Sting.
-Yes! That's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The password is...shrimp.
-Alright, Jimmy, why don't you
start us off?
-Mm-hmm.
-No cheating.
-Oh. no.
Yes, dear?
[ Laughter ]
Come on. Use your words.
-Scampi.
-Um...
-Crustacean.
-[ Laughs ] Oh.
Oh. Oh, The old overthought.
-[ Laughs ]
Kevin. Kevin, it's your turn.
-Holy...
-I don't know if Tariq
is going to get this.
-Okay, let's see.
Um...
-Oh, my God.
Now I know the answer.
-Boiled?
-Shrimp?
-Oh!
my, oh, my.
-5-zero.
-Are you a teacher?
-Wait! No, let me make it
very clear!
-"Crustacean scampi"?
-A crustacean is a shrimp.
-I know.
-Yeah. Classic overthinking.
-I thought we were doing
smart answers.
-I was a little bit worried.
-Crustacean scampi.
-It just sounded too easy.
-That's American TV.
-Oh.
-Alright.
Next clue goes to Tan and Tariq.
-Alright, we got this, Tan.
-The password is...Madonna.
-You are up first.
-Mm. Mm.
-Don't overthink it.
[ Laughter ]
-Virgin.
-Ooh. Ooh.
-Mary?
-Ooh.
-No.
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-Vogue.
-Madonna.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Whoa.
Well, the score --
-Of course the gays got --
Well, the gay got that.
The score is Sammy Hagar --
55.
Jimmy and Kevin,
next clue's for you.
-The password is...tuxedo.
-Kevin, why don't you
start us off?
-Oh, I go first?
Okay.
Formal.
-Tuxedo?
-Oh! Wham!
Wow.
Wow. Wow.
-He's such a good actor.
He's like, "Formal."
-Tan would've said, "Attire".
[ Laughter ]
-I was literally thinking,
"Attire".
When have you
ever seen a casual tuxedo?
-That's true.
-Alright, final clue
goes to Tan and Tariq.
-Mm-hmm.
-The password is...robot.
-Tan, why don't
you start us off?
-Mm.
You got this, bud.
-Oh, I don't know if this is
the name of an American show
or an English show.
-That's alright.
I watch a lot of things.
-Okay.
Wars.
[ Laughter ]
If we were in England right now,
he would know.
It's not my fault
you're not British.
-Okay. "Wars".
Oh, gosh.
[British accent] "Wars".
-I said it in an American accent
for you.
[American accent] Wars.
-[Normal voice] I know,
but there's no wars, right?
There's no show "Wars".
-[Normal voice] No.
-There's [British accent]
"Wars".
It's not "Star Wars"
because it's a show.
[Normal voice] So, I'm gonna say
it's like...
Is it, like, "Closet Wars"?
-Ooh, no.
-I don't even know what that is.
-Negative.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
I got it.
-R2-D2
-Star?
-Oh.
-Oh!
-Oh! Hey!
-Hold on. Hold on.
-You can say anything.
I think I know it.
-Alright. Cool it.
Cool it.
-Sorry. We got this.
-Machine.
Robot!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
Tonight, it's Tariq Trotter,
Kevin Bacon,
Tan France and I --
the champions!